hi everyone welcome back to resident
evil today's a big day it's a very
special day it's our Centennial those
are not right I'm not Mary Mary messed
that up
she's not my guess who did the lower
thirds again that was Mary who's today
is dressed as Jill Valentine
I'm Jill Valentine she wanted to
celebrate the hundreds that we both said
we were going to for the final for the
hundredth episode I also yeah you
brought like a holster and everything
Jill Valentine from one of us did it
well I'm wearing my shining shirt resin
evil 3 nemesis her outfit looks good
that's probably good and I didn't get a
wig in time I don't know if security
would have let you in if you had a gun
yeah I bet I didn't even feel good like
wearing it to the office like I just put
a big sweater over its Knievel day they
know anyway we'll get to the episode
like a little bit but Mary oh yeah I
need something for a night to watch this
is for the fans I made this for you guys
to celebrate yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
am I going check the map not your night
I'm broken I'm actually I'm actually
broken oh no what oh my god
right now
[Music]
Jesus [ __ ]
[Music]
you're covered in dog oh [ __ ] trip mine
trip line and dogs
the dress had no armor there
[Music]
[Music]
what a horrible shitty ass camera why
Alexia
I
it's not
thanks Mary
gonna keep it game pip thanks everyone
you're welcome so the funny story behind
that is is I was gonna do a hundred
scares for 100 episodes and I got all of
the scares from 100 episodes and the
video was 10 minutes long and I was like
nobody wants to hear the mic peaking for
10 minutes so I reduced it to like 3
minutes and I just picked like 3 or 4
moments from every game that I like I
think it's better that way I'm like
happier with the way it is anyway yeah
you so much to everybody who's been here
for all 100 episodes or if you just
joined us come on in welcome the waters
just fine we're gonna be playing or
sharks in it Resident Evil 0 now and I'm
on my third episode and I've been
learning a lot every episode I've
learned a great deal I think before yeah
I've already learned so much
yes usually I got a lot of hints already
from you guys I appreciate that so like
one of the major things that I saw in
the comments was who was it that said
that a lot of people stopped separating
okay is what they said like stop stop
breaking up the gang yeah they're meant
to be together and I'm like ruining the
system what I'm doing so well I'm not
helping I keep them together and they
also told me throw away the shit-ass gun
even if it nice - I said even if it has
two bullets in it they were like it's
like you forget it mind if it's trash so
I'm just gonna like you can continue
reading stuff to me but I'm gonna which
one is is it this one no the hunting
rifle
yeah this one hunting gun so I'm just
gonna
bless it every [ __ ] time I do that so
hhhh hbk 718 said another tip is this
game is meant to be used both characters
the majority of it so it's better than
ever get both of them at all times to
handle situations easier more easily I
personally use Billy's lead character in
Rebecca as an assistant and also people
said don't turn off the auto attack
right so um yeah someone else said that
as well which was like the good news
about their auto attack is that they
don't miss unlike me so it's more
accurate if they hit if they let them
shoot yeah
all right so someone hold me do it
examine my lighter so we've got some
awesome people who do like fan art every
once in a while and we have I've reached
out to one of them to get something
working and so for the next episode
we're Amy we're aiming for the next
episode it's you know the show's not too
rigid so maybe we'll I'll show you
whatever but we're doing like a
commitment or the commemorative
hundredth episode fan art thing and then
Xavier I apologize I'm forgetting name
right now I believe like Funko pop
mock-ups pretty funny but that's always
thank you everybody for hanging out with
us once a week sometimes twice at the
beginning and sometimes not all right
let's get going I put this [ __ ] so my
lighters had a fuel that's why I
couldn't light the lantern and the
previous episode so I need to find fuel
for it I tried to combine it with this
gas can and it said no so I got to find
that's what we need to do right now okay
okay so tell me what to do you got the
shortcut back I think you got to go back
up yes I know you got to do all right I
think I need some bullets maybe because
I like don't you want to heal Rebecca or
know how [ __ ] is she
let's see she's not great she's on
orange but I did just save but I only
have seven bullets and a shotgun and
she's
more she's got like okay but it's not a
lot like we're not not doing great
go back Tory go I read the what does
that thing this it's the projector
Philip I don't have a projector yet so
you want to go back upstairs and use the
shortcut that you unlock but he do I
want to heal her yeah come on those
other people said maybe used Billy
whenever possible because he could take
more damage and the computer is probably
gonna void it easier okay in terms of
how to get back to that room um I can
pull up them out yeah for people
wondering the compilation video that
Mary made I'll put that up separately on
YouTube and GameSpot as well so it'll be
part of this episode part of that okay
so here's the map let's focus right so
that's the it's up a floor for sure I'm
on the upstairs floor it's down a floor
then or up one more can you go up to the
third floor uh or like press up on the
d-pad there you go yeah it's up there
those stairs to the right remember you
yeah isn't there like a bad guy no
they're in here go up here okay
yeah I'll put that video up separately
if you want to watch that okay how was
your packs I was with you most of it I
know we did like stock we like went to a
lot of bars the first night was a late
night that one was - that was rough on
Mary the next day was yeah I haven't
been in this pool yet there's like a
pool that's this is what we're doing
there's like a puzzle issue okay oh and
yes I remember I remember now okay
there's like down here we didn't go
there yet go over to this stuff okay I
believe there's something going on
around here
it's a machine for winding the chain
start the machine sure oh he's so strong
okay uh maybe she wants you should have
done that with her instead okay so
here's my initial instinct is telling me
that there's gonna be something you're
fighting down there right and someone's
gonna have to drop that cage on them
right so I would take Billy down to
fight assuming the person up here will
be safe if that make sense oh Jesus
Christ
what is she strong enough okay it has to
be him
gotcha she's not strong enough jerks
[Music]
mother-loving happened so fast
mother-lovin have me best oh I'm such an
ass
alright never mind sorry I got it
imagine that falling on you it would
kill you well not if it fell around you
so I have to watch this like hulky bro
rotate your complaining um alright so
I'm gonna go down there now okay okay oh
wait
remember that grenade launcher we ran
into that we didn't get yet okay Oh
balls
what the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
dude what do I do
I'll fight him scorpion loading well I'm
[ __ ] out of ammo
I'm assuming that cage has something to
do with it are you serious yeah I don't
have any ammo to do this like I
straight-up don't have the ammo to
handle this don't seem like an attack
is it gonna kill you go down and see
what you can do down there
oh the ladders gone
all the cages over there
yeah it is but he's not down there no no
it's it's up here but it's back there
right above him right now oh [ __ ] I see
I see probably gonna move by then but
you can try what's what's alright try
the far right thing
can you unwind it or I mean doesn't give
me any option okay I'm out of ammo so
hope there you go maybe have to wipe
well yeah unless we know what I'm
supposed to be doing I like don't have
any ammo I can't save her she's gonna
die
use your lighter yeah I don't know maybe
wife go to another room try to find that
grenade launcher I know what the grenade
locking Who am I supposed to fight him
or am I supposed to use them yeah but
you don't have anything if you said [ __ ]
she doesn't look so hot
[Music]
she's still alive I don't know I mean
I'm Dean like I'm not doing well she's
annoying
cuz I thought wasn't play as her like it
looks like I could be able to like drop
that thing but it won't let me wonder
why it's a no need anymore
well how about just let him kill Billy
and we'll reset to figure that stuff out
because you barely did anything yet okay
it's got a little end so now that we
know he's got a fight there's that
grenade launcher in the room with the
two crawler things right so I could take
it'll be for all hours but I don't know
if I have grenades they're gonna be
there there were some in it when you
pick it up see if you picked it up in
them I need more what I need more
coaching on this oh I don't even
remember at all figure it out I don't
want to like look up hints yet
because it's we can but but I died well
you did it on purpose
all right and maybe bring some healing
stuff with Billy and I know he's gonna
fight he has a spray oh right good
oh I have a malt off how about that I
think you want to save those
specifically for those other dudes
how many shotgun shells you have one
didn't you
can you open your map and see if you
have any other shotgun shells lying
around
right unless so that's this floor I
believe
No hmm this is like all the mo I have in
my assistance
she'll hurry up regardless I would say
so she is healed I want to give this to
him where is that option why can't I
give him stuff
[Music]
gave him all of the bullets but I don't
think that that's gonna help so go to
the hunting gun on her like there's no
way to separate those in this game is
there no we tried that last time okay
I mean yeah I leave it regardless anyway
why cuz you don't need that remember you
said that was like the number one tip
everybody told you I I like I disagree
I've decided to shoot someone with it
they're two [ __ ] shotgun shells I'm
gonna use them end of story okay
be stubborn about it go get the we need
the grenade launcher for sure okay well
let's go get the grenade launcher yeah
so through the same door from here and
then like I already have two [ __ ]
bullets in it I'm just gonna shoot him
I'm going to shoot shoot them with them
that's what I've decided to do no
objection here I won't hear another word
about my use of this shitty gun that
I've accidentally loaded so it's in here
you remember what was in here those two
- yeah and you don't want me to use a
multi bond them no there's a grenade
launcher and I believe hopefully
grenades
it'll be loaded yeah but there's another
ammo - I think where are they oh did you
kill them maybe I must have
oh sweet okay shotgun shells oh good
okay good angle okay so I'm gonna become
Billy and I'm gonna have Billy take this
yes I don't think he has room right now
does he I don't know yeah that's fine Oh
see what you have him pick up the
shotgun shells oh yeah keep that in mind
what he's gonna pick up the shotgun
shells as well okay um honestly just he
could drop this for now like what is he
gonna do with one of them or are you he
could drop drop the pistol in the in the
Emma the other room though I know it's
annoying to backtrack but it's worth
doing that's fine for here right now you
get the grenade launcher and you still
have and you get a shotgun shells
although once you reload the shotgun
shells you might load all those I forget
how many his gun holds
um he already has one in there so it's
not gonna be one shotgun shell that's
[ __ ] rude no no no I'm saying once
you reload I wonder if he already has
one in there right so now we'll combine
them I'm trying to member how what the
max is that has hold at a time so it's
gonna be one yeah
[Music]
I would still keep that extra shotgun
shell because that's powerful
[Music]
what is she having her inventory right
now
nothing she can take the bullets but
once she's captured she can't use them
yeah you don't need to I she's gonna
need the space for the key anyway I
think it's fine those those are good
here okay so we're fighting this thing
now
yes am i using the grenade launcher yes
okay based on some helpful tips we I
don't cuz she's in there I think I would
kill her but yeah that's what I'm
curious what will happen well we'll find
out stop looking at tips I'm not looking
at tips yes you are waiting for you to
do something
what do you mean I what happened to
going in blind why is everybody need us
to succeed on the first time I like the
I like you failing I did fail now I wish
to succeed nobody was on purpose
we need Mike and Mary amiibo and a big
dope oh so you can't Juke enemies and 0
so people are saying kill them oh I
would have saved me some frickin health
I was like trying to be this little Juke
Queen alright so she's about to get
captured take the facility so that's
probably the ice are fired full fire if
it's red remember you saw fire locked
doors
I do but where did this come from just a
giant centipede
and before I thought giant crab all
right so when how many shelled creatures
how he rears up and roars that's when
you want him with a grenade launcher
okay just - oh so he doesn't actually go
out of his way to attack you so don't
just don't stand in that path that where
he walks and you'll be fine mm-hmm I
like this song a John Carpenter kind of
[ __ ] all right is he reared does that
count no like I don't think so
he's hurting her yeah you heard him for
sure I just don't know how she didn't
get hurt I mean that's like a Resident
Evil issue yeah you're in the bathroom
[Music]
yeah you I think you're doing it I think
I'm doing
I'm gonna save you down good way to
start off the hundred episode boss fight
whether you succeed or not oh oh right
there did he die no that's when you want
it
oh I [ __ ] miss wait she just died no
he dropped her and then picked her up oh
my god was I supposed to become her and
then run away
I hate that's might be giving this game
too much credit I'm fairly certain
you're supposed to kill him like right
now right now no no no you're gonna miss
[ __ ] I'm out the shotgun now it's
annoying I don't think you need to wait
for it to roar now come on really
I mean well actually no yeah way from
never want to see stupid face
[Music]
damnit how much ammo does this take it's
hard to see I'm not blaming you I'm like
am i shooting em nice yeah I know resin
evil is the early ones this isn't this
is later obviously GameCube title you
think they wouldn't put four different
camera angles in or five whatever eyes I
mean I think they do on purpose I think
they enjoy my stress I see how [ __ ] up
okay good
nobody took any damage so that's great
so you could drop the grenade launcher
in the lobby
well reload the shotgun first before I
forget okay no no not here bring it down
just so you have it down there I mean
you're upstairs but you never know
what's gonna go on between these two
rooms later you see what you're yawning
and then also you think that's trying
this I was trying to get it out before
alright gonna keep it
keeping the lobby alright I say I think
sorry bring it down in the lobby just so
that like like other people recommended
keep it like one big item box and
there's nothing else to pick up up here
and you can examine the key right now
bless you thank you
zoom tight yeah I don't know what it is
I might have the PAX pox hopefully not
it's got the fire logo on it so it's the
fire key so that opens up all sorts of
doors I'm pleased again the triple
sneeze I mean I hope I don't
I like I'm too busy to be sick right now
I leave tomorrow to go to LA we're doing
a stand up to cancer stream it's like a
charity in anti cancer charity okay so I
have like no [ __ ] ammo oh do you want
to get that we should get his gun back
shouldn't we yeah I'm just gonna do that
right now so just go around using the
fire key whenever well your map do you
remember which ones are the fire doors
because I don't off the top my head so
you only ran into two different types of
doors there's fire and ice on it correct
I don't know if it was as far as I
remember oh yeah so just the khalsa
people out sorry give a few good shouts
nico petits Mahalo Desmond bushing that
butchering that says always bring both
characters yes thank you very much use
Billy as your main character on that as
well he has a higher chance of getting a
head shot with a pistol
maybe he's taller that's a nice tourism
drop the hunting gun you can't headshot
zombies of it
combine the two fuels so it doesn't take
two spaces on the floor what that's cool
I didn't know you could take you guys
read this we did Nikko thank you so much
all right sorry that's that's great but
let's talk about where we're gonna go
yeah and then once I like have a
direction you can keep doing that okay
so I don't know where I'm going I mean I
can just aimlessly walk around okay I'm
I don't want to tell you exactly because
I'll keep warm on the top floor what
about this red door over here you want
it's on this floor you want to go
through the classroom all right so let's
go to the classroom but yeah it's fine
did you get the ammo and the handgun yes
okay how dare you know I'm getting the
sniffles okay um it's either the door
right off here or you just have to keep
going no I think I remember I was no
hold on like there's a there's a red
line here so I was gonna try that okay
it looks like that's not a key that's
like those swords that are crossed
oh [ __ ] I might've made a mistake then
yes you're correct all right and then
what's this no I think you want to go
through the bottom left or and then it's
one of those okay cuz the one at the
very bottom left is that one we have to
light the candle that we can't figure
out I think there's [ __ ] zombies in
here
oh no the lighter wasn't working cuz you
did enough fuel in it so now maybe you
could light that candle do you know what
I'm talking about
the lighter didn't have fuel but was
there fuel in that room why would you
need fuel in that room if you blew
because though lighter doesn't it fuel
there's two you fuel down in the main
room no I combined you are never [ __ ]
pay attention sorry she hurt did Billy
save you I don't know I combined them in
the Verret that's like the very first
thing I did and it didn't work
so that does not work so we still don't
know how to get fuel in the lighter no
gotcha unless you know you like know
something that I don't it
sweet this is probably like one more if
I I wonder if it's worth getting rid of
oh I can't believe I [ __ ] got a hole
in two caution from that's really
annoying I was doing so good
soon we could push that little thing I
hope so
okay good well if I was supposed to pull
it wait Han don't can you climb over it
buddies present ax just point of putting
that there is weird isn't it sick
shotgun handgun nice okay so don't know
assistant directors diary a useless
bunch of trainees had a couple decent
ones William an Albert
Albert Wesker William Birkin hmm courage
rivalry between the two orders are
orders
I'm going to have them tearing at each
other's throats yeah interesting all
right so I'm gonna let her take the
handgun rounds and I'm gonna switches
him what do you have left for the
hunting on one shell one shell maybe two
for her does he have room for this
actually no no he's out of ammo he's
good
okay so he'll take these I'll have him
convinced I'd recommend pulling your
handgun out with him
I don't think you need a shotgun right
now and he's gonna use those okay seven
bullets but I can give him he's got 21
okay you're right he's saying what does
she have she you might as well let her
use the last of those then drop it we
are on the same page here for once sweet
that button is very ominous you know I'm
going to push it and you interact with
the fireplace it looks highly detailed
no
button
hmm that's [ __ ] the only time that
turning on lights makes me uncomfortable
there's a moose Oh earring what I shoot
it no no no no push the thing oh I see
but so if I push it over if I put him
here yeah then he should be able to push
it forward right oh you [ __ ] idiot
I'll go okay I don't think I need to
have someone there like as long as you
just leave enough space I said what I
said I'm not gonna have him [ __ ] this
up so I'm like a little afraid here that
I'm gonna [ __ ] this up
push so every year my family my Irish
side of the family has a ball they're
both Irish oh [ __ ] I pick the wrong
person one side my family is a family
reunion thing and there's this the place
we stay they're both full you could give
the handgun ammo to him for now
just so he's that or vice versa honestly
yeah that's a good idea I don't even
know what that man is you're picking up
and there's this stuffed deer and as a
joke one year I just carried her right
it's huge - it's like the size of that
one and I carried it around with me the
entire week and I know what that is
that's the minute hand from that clock
oh I don't member where the clock is it
was uh where the grenade launcher is Oh
also I remember where the other fire
door is - okay so do you wanna do fire
yeah just Roger fired wait so I wonder
what if that turned on the power
elsewhere I don't know like what the
[ __ ] was the point of turning that power
on just so I would resist that we would
don't be the ear I guess I mean is there
something else I'm supposed to know - I
don't think so
I didn't notice anything else
yeah I don't I don't see anything else
okay you open your map when you get the
chance sure I can do it okay right now
is it here
I think there's bad guys somewhere in
here I just can't remember where but I
have enough ammo no to kill them I think
okay go down a floor on the map oh you
want to see it down yeah um I believe
that's a fire door to the far right this
guy yeah okay also you can get the
hookshot and you can get back to that
room you came from that's and I don't
have the hookshot no I know
to get the hookshot remember you tried
we thought you were locked off from the
crash site you're not oh the door you
came through that hatch not the door
there's a hatch in the floor that we
haven't really looking at okay all right
so we're going back to downstairs that's
what you want yes so you'll be able to
get rid of the fire key hopefully if
this is the right door
wait am i doing this wrong yeah I am
doing this wrong
yeah if this is right then I can get rid
of another item which would be nice but
I have a needle so I'll do that after
the fire door is that what you're saying
cuz I know where the thing is
any whatever's closer honestly I mean
here but you're freeing up space with
both you can go do that the one that's
closer is here o'clock yeah because it's
it's in here okay yeah do that you might
as well you're freeing up space I'm
pretty sure I mean I doubt it's gonna
trigger a boss fight so very funny if it
said Kingston yeah well they remember
that other advice I got was save more
like don't do this do you have enough
ribbons though like how many ribbons
dude I didn't think I did you had but I
have more from the Train so if you're
saying I can get back to the Train I
think I know so this is the clock I
thought it stopped ticking altogether oh
wait did I [ __ ] up yeah I thought it was
here no I'm trying to member I think it
was farther so let's just do the fire
thing we'll figure that I would all
right I forgot sorry yeah we'll just
don't do that again she's getting cuz I
never forget her don't pay attention
that's true hey what if we combine the
gas cans with the lighter Mary you
missed I already said that doesn't work
I've got it
well combine the gas cans with a lighter
correct girl you got your pyrotechnics
down okay so we're gonna go down here
into the right I'd you really I just
don't know I really do
I hope there's not bad stuff in here
there anyway I thought you had to go
down another floor oh I don't know maybe
the stairs are in here oh my [ __ ] god
oh you are in the right way okay ah that
guy looks scary what should I do
come on do you have your shotgun out put
your hand she's got her shotgun but I
want her to use it because she's trash
should I be her well okay
get your handgun out like don't don't
use shotgun shells on him okay
and then yeah just let her lure him
toward you guys so she can use the rest
of those shells oh there's the penis
things
god I hope there's only one penises
penis she should be out and he's dead
yes
I hear another one oh my god hey go hey
you use both of them effectively
well I scared myself he saved them kind
of Oh cuz he's out of ammo holy [ __ ]
look at his gun I like a little detail
rounds oh maybe split in half was he
just gonna like sit there you gotta give
her something um I'll give her this yeah
he was he's gonna [ __ ] take a charm
for you
Chomp Chomp Chomp Chomp azam azam be
that was efficient the way I did that
just now I'm very impressed with myself
fire door Billy I have a key you idiot
you [ __ ] idiot
so I wanna play as Billy right when I
can yeah
just want to make sure did he reload his
gun looks like it yes yeah i reloaded it
the window is open that doesn't make me
feel good it makes me feel bad I don't
like it
go close that window Rebecca Rebecca and
Billa ooh
oh that looks like lighter fluid it does
look like later I was joking does it it
is lighter fluid deluxe lighter fluid
you might as well combine that now
because I want to know warning this is
flammable please don't drink this it
could cause birth defects such as mother
love tattoos oh I like it it flips open
when it's full I wonder how I'm like
there's gotta be something else in here
so now you can light that candle right
though there's a bottle then I make a
Molly I could make a Molly okay is that
it then Jesus [ __ ] did it say that we
had more doors to open
no you tossed the key way I did yes but
now with the lighter ready you can oh
you have the grandfather clock and the
lighter so I have two things to do right
now I have no clue where the grandfather
clock wait wait wait wait just to save
space go back to the main like make a
Molly or drop the bottle you're right
and maybe save you've done enough now
where you could say you think so okay I
definitely don't wanna restart from here
we've done at least 30 minutes of a
solid investigative work if that's what
you want to call it yeah that is what I
want to call it okay
I will return for you
but I don't want them no well I mean
unless you run into those things well
what if I do then you'll come back here
for him what's the what's the term you
better save before sorry just kidding
[Music]
was that just one puck I don't feel like
I have a lot of saves
okay so Huck's here I'll use it but like
what's the long term can evil plan here
you know that is an oxymoron if I've
ever heard I don't think we ever have a
plan um I mean if what people are saying
is true you can head through that hatch
to the crash site and get all those
ribbons we could try that after the same
okay you are kind of fighting the bullet
by already saving the way I know you did
enough where it justifies this I agree
but go to the left side of the stairs I
think that's where the ladder wasn't the
map sorry like past yeah hatch that's
where you came from as people pointed
out I thought we came from the door you
did in the first game that's probably
yeah this is their [ __ ] in there no
remember you came through here unless
I mean yes there technically it's sewage
how much stuff do I have on me though
oh you had to ink ribbons that's all
right I have two slots on her in one and
some adults about God so I have three
slots opens so that's got to be worth
something
hook shots too though [ __ ] I should have
emptied my pocket did this journey
that's your pocket fit more puppies good
all right so you get those and a knife
what you don't need
okay well then there you go five of them
I wonder how many it was I don't know
one no I was three I had three you had
one I thought I had to you had to used
one then you had one then you got three
more it has four well we got a
mathematician here oh hey do me a favor
shoot the hook shot into those flames
and see what happens pull them into the
embers
well I hate getting into knee-deep water
do you do that often you know and life
calls okay drop your box girl in the
hookshot I feel like if I could just say
so it's not the amount of items per
space it's the amount of space around
the items if you leave it around other
items like the density yeah okay so as
long as there's space on the floor
you're fine but to stop it from
accidentally not being able to pick [ __ ]
up it doesn't let you like drop eight
items in one corner but you can have
twenty items in a room which is why I
was going to argue that you should just
have a [ __ ] item box because it like
alleviates all these problems the
problems of like there are times when
you've been able to just drop something
no matter where you were I think you're
still tied to the item boxes yeah
alright so are we doing the lighter now
are we doing the clock now cuz I know
weird it's do the lighter because we
know where that is we know where that is
so we're gonna go up in here right yeah
and it's like in here something that's
that red one it's in this red no orange
the red door to the left that's it okay
yeah okay so there's also a green herb
up here if you want to get it and bring
it back down in this area it was on your
item list it might be on the floor above
okay well she's on COSO maybe I'll just
have her take it because if there's a
boss fight coming up she gonna need it
no you just had one I don't I mean there
might be
I get so [ __ ] lost or outdoors area
that's why you need a map you check your
lap map
what game was that - was that for one
game where you like really don't need to
it was like - it was like early on in
the series and you were like checking
your map too much I was like I need it I
like looking at my map you do enough
backtracking in this game as is alright
Billy do your thing you big dum-dum
alright thank you it worked
remember how like confused we were less
of a so we're like just light it yeah
idiot and so you did enough you'll just
ugh we had to examine it yeah okay in
case you couldn't figure out what that
you need to light the candle look at a
Santa Claus over here are you gonna tell
us the story of why you peeped in a
urinal oh yeah thanks after this are you
gonna help me or what I feel like she
didn't shoot very much ask
yes I was when was it I was going to a
football game grenades let's go to a
football game and we had I had drank a
decent amount back when I drank more and
I went into this bathroom like off a
parking lot like when we got back to
where we parked our car after Stadium
and I was with a sibling of mine I'm
trying to specify as little as possible
cuz this actually happened and then I
went to the bathroom and I had to poop
very badly and in my drunken state I
thought oh I'll poop and I'll poop in
this urinal like as a joke no not really
as a joke half joke half emergency I was
about to poop my pants but there wasn't
a toilet no oh sorry crucial information
these stalls were both taken up one by a
friend of mine and one by a stranger so
I thought oh I'll just really quickly
prove in this urinal and in my drunken
state it didn't occur to me that were
it's gonna still be in there when I'm
okay it's gonna be in there when I'm
done so and I didn't tell anybody I was
gonna do it so they looked over and it
was just happening well what's this no
please go on about you [ __ ] and okay
to specify it so by the time when this
episode airs I'll be living in Europe no
I'll it'll be my birthday like two weeks
after I'm in my upper 20s now mid 20s
upper right this happened when I was 20
so it was a while ago I didn't poop in a
urinal recently the book of good anyway
so I took a dump in a urinal
and I left very quickly that's got to be
like a hollowed-out book right I think
so did you get those grenades yes
there's a joke I was paying I know just
pushing it the other way just to see if
there was anything else so that's the
story - some details riveting I was
drinking maker's mark all day oh I know
what that is more oh we do know what
that's for let's go to the clock before
you put those on okay wait but the black
thing only has one wing and wonder if
you needed a sec up another wing for you
probably need another wing so we could
drop that off but I still don't know
where the clock is so honestly the next
thing we need to do is figure out where
the frickin clock is is there anything
else I always feel like a missing stuff
in this one for some reason okay so we
did this so is there anything else in
this room that like we missed oh right
that's like the one that sends you
upstairs but we already did that do we
need to do actually hold on that word
thing yes that's where the clock is who
has the well I can give it to whoever
you want wait is the lift upstairs I can
bring it back down I think I know it
broke well you got the upstairs through
the wet room again alright okay so
alright so sorry what do you want to do
first we can drop off the angel's wings
cuz it's pretty close just get rid of it
don't put them on the statues why not
cuz if it's probably gonna trigger
something not on because you get if you
want to do those go for it I will cuz I
think you need the black wing
ok so I think we're not ready yet and I
think we're just getting rid of an item
that I don't want to carry around is how
I feel about it but you could also just
drop it on the floor and any in the room
that's what I'm why did we put the
thingies on the thingy in the first
place then if we could just because we
didn't know that they weren't gonna
trigger we don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
okay I'm gonna laugh if this triggers a
[ __ ] dragon and just comes and melts
you but I agree I sticks my initial idea
that you'll probably sexual statue some
serious buns on that lady is that what
you call them buns yeah I call them buns
oh wait oh I got it here we go
removing yas combine spied on my babies
I have down okay
let's find that clock bra now I don't
have the what an ugly photo that dude
painting picture
oh I did get maxed out in this room I
was wrong forget no I'm not just because
you're on the landing maybe let's find
out okay anyway you could pick up the
grenade launcher anyway put them in
there
oh I could do that that's smart I was
gonna pick up these gas cans and combine
them cuz then that makes it one item
like that defies physics because the
rest of this game so realistic there's a
there's a lot going on in this game
that's like why but you know Who am I to
like pay any and all right so there's
grenade alright so I yeah I've freed up
a lot of space here so that's shotgun
shells he probably wants those right
yeah I think so what's his handgun ammo
like not great maybe give him some she's
got she doesn't have that many yeah
gee is that the option 15 or like
nothing like get [ __ ] I would give the
majority to you I don't know who you is
I'm both of them
oh here's the shotgun nevermind maybe
your oh it that's annoying as hell
alright I've made it I've made it call
okay you're just gonna tell me where the
clock is um I'm gonna deal with them
wasn't that only one shotgun shell
though listen I've made an executive
decision can I need you to tell me where
the clock is go upstairs do the
centipede boss battle room
got it I'm looking forward to
revelations too because I get to play
again I'm not you'll see it I'm not
gonna be doing much but I'll be playing
mm-hmm you sound so excited I am if
people don't know if you just joined
we're trying to we're not trying we're
going to we're gonna beat this and then
play Revelations one and two before
January it's September now if we if it
comes to it like we we have to if it
comes to it we'll start like busting out
a lot of this game and those games by
January for resonable to remake this
specified
here that mm-hmm oh you have to go
through the CRO thing remember yeah but
just keep moving right where am I going
oh they [ __ ] back this road me thank
you
she's not so bad Oh almost crude you can
fight like a crow fight milk made for
bodyguards by bodyguards all right
clocks in here there it is Alfred are
yes I do
[ __ ] uh do you remember the time yeah
8:15 my watch doesn't work oh come on
okay for our hand
eight yeah this clock is not correct
technically technically should be a
little past eight but yeah that's it
it's be pedantic yes ever get away for
eight of those Oh
where was that I don't know this mansion
is very dumb though Oh
oh I'll be red anymore I [ __ ] hope so
well that second one was just straight
off the upstairs balcony so that's easy
sometimes I think she's a zombie and she
scares me
and she walks closer to me like that
cool well we got a lot done now what
that's some crow Ally I think we have to
because there's no other way to get out
of here she's it it just pisses me off
cuz like [ __ ] off oh you're good
are there any other items in here I
might grab them now okay now and then
what's that arrow pointing down you can
jump down should I yeah we haven't done
it yet do something do not [ __ ]
touching the elevator would it
what the [ __ ] all right I don't know
what to say
[ __ ] off I love you doesn't look like
she got cautioned Eric Schmidt I gotten
cautioned she already was unconscious
because I [ __ ] up so one of those
doors was definitely on the upper floor
I'm assuming you'll do something Clocky
to open all those doors yeah I feel like
it's clock II was it first floor do me
just I don't know it might show up in
your map let me go downstairs and let's
go to the lobby and we'll check the map
I have a feeling the reason it showed it
to us because it was like do you do you
remember where they are based on these
very brief image from a weird angle yeah
one's definitely here yeah they're both
hoping now it's that one to the right
and then upstairs I mean sorry it's one
of these I think cuz it's upstairs see
no it's that one the other one it's like
one of these I think or wait no no cuz
those are all great is that it's that
it's no it was near a window and at the
end of the hallway
okay why don't we just do the first one
okay so it's this one here and then
we'll do the next one okay and then
we'll then we'll figure it out
all right so it's this no is the one
you've passed I thought creep
well that's really weird yeah sorry yeah
my way
idiot Becky stupid Western outfit no
okay that's where I step in that thing
is [ __ ] sick assassin all right here
zombies she is on caution food stars
member I hear another one we have to
talk about these things
yeah equip the shotgun why not cuz he's
being attacked once he throws it off
like just a shotgun so wait hold on
I'd say as Rebecca just focused Billy
can take damage he takes a lot as a
Rebecca I just focus on continuing to
shoot the guy you're shooting at right
now okay
once he throws him off we can worry
about that that was bad you cooked that
does she have the handgun is she she's
15 rounds
all right worth it I don't think so that
was bad oh sweet a moon vows to the
earth the earth swears loyalty to the
Sun the great law of the Sun governs all
things this is like a scale of moon
earth Sun yeah it's definitely a puzzle
okay this itself is the keystone stone
the pointer took glory all our hands
cannot open the door to heaven that's
them yeah okay so it should have written
it down moon earth Sun I can't believe I
got that hurt that sucks
they both [ __ ] took hits that sucks
it's just frustrating cuz more microfilm
no no you take the microfilm cuz you're
the microfilm lady okay anything else
somebody took a picture out of that
frame I don't see anything else did you
see anything else there's a clock over
here just making sure I'm not forgetting
anything on this table do you see
anything else
no okay well I got microfilm but I don't
want to do with it it must be in one of
those other doors that we unlocked yeah
it's the damn I can't believe I got
double hurt open your map again
go down to the first floor okay
it is it's that door this door yes
okay so we're going down into the left
and you have both microfilm with you
remote micro films uh yes I should do
you want to heal up you have there no
they're both on caution they're both not
in danger so but he went from green to
orange I saw that but I think crow got
him like are we doing a boss that's my
question okay well then there might be
some times always sure as long as he's
got the shotgun ready should I should
play as him all right and then let me
just double-check that they have enough
ammo that's so annoying that you can't
give him a better that's good there's
like none of ammo to go around I think
is what bothers me you know like okay
should I give him the other five bullets
cuz then she doesn't have anything you
don't Amy in legs
okay I'm gonna play as him and I'm just
gonna like [ __ ] shoot anything that
comes near me
we're not taking any damage do you hear
me handle room damn angles okay
it's this door okay you ready okay no
damage no damage no damage no puzzles no
puzzles no puzzles what is it Billy is
my back I heard me in [ __ ] I'm not
[ __ ] around what in the future you
can get head shots with a shotgun
remember I thought they said you
couldn't you can't with a hunting gun
you didn't you didn't take damage to
your finding either way sweet there's a
projector right there oh yeah oh my god
was that is that just rot I thought it
was um claw marks yeah oh that's good
for Rebecca come get this girl anyway
yeah okay anything else all right
let's check out this film
yeah yes I do I hate all right hold on
leave right this out
I mean it's just one two three four five
six seven oh yeah eight nine and then
after nine it goes a bunny I don't know
yeah okay well we can go do this I just
didn't know if we were gonna do it
before the end of you are we gonna do it
sure I don't think you're gonna trigger
a boss or anything do you want to look
at it again no it went up to F yeah yeah
yeah yep
sweet and you got an MMO disc M Oh disco
disc sweet oh and we can always a kiss
in image that's nice okay so what would
you like to do now go back to that
classroom I know cooking health for a
long ass home it's got the first days
right don't don't you have the red and
green in the manor I do but I do I do
[Music]
yeah don't use them yet
I I think we should wait look I I don't
think I'm doing great
no but I think I could you're the second
half I said I can take one more hit I
hope Oh
Molotov would be great what is it based
on the music it's the thing that you
want the molotov soir well I don't have
that my didn't know you were gonna run
into that I can't get out of this
[ __ ] hallway well okay here heal up
you know I don't even think you need to
heal up so you can like stagger it with
a shock of this stuff this sucks
can you go maybe reset go through the
door again and see what happens no he's
gonna be there oh you got seven shotgun
shells I'll still be able to do damage
but I can't uh one of us is gonna die
she doesn't have any health on her so go
first as Billy like go first I don't
want to die here yes Oh keel up will
find more healing items okay so shields
are arms it'll be worth it go first and
shoot good thing yeah try to stagger and
then just run by okay or even kill it I
don't like shots that will do damage
that's good you should knock it down run
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay okay where am I going
door to your left
did I won't go past it so he's fine I
would take okay use okay great on so I
went past it sandy did but she didn't
I'm more worried about her because he's
still on fine okay got it
you should switch to her or use the
right analog stick got it got it they
just get her away from it like run her
right toward okay now oh my god Wow okay
sweet are we okay
yeah you're you didn't take any damage
she did didn't know she did it
he got hit but he definitely got hit
he's someone fine though okay just
random that is weird
I didn't realize you could open doors
with your secondary character like you
just did did you or did I miss something
yeah oh so okay I went into this screen
and I hit triangle and it changes your
characters in the screen oh that's what
I did okay do the microfilm thing and
there's multiple ways to change your
character and one of them I noticed is
in your item select screen okay so you
save now and then go do the microphone
thing or to go to the classroom and do
those microfilm thing in the classroom
you bring those with you use the map
from that thing and then um you want
call an episode there I've got this
written down we've got the thing how
long has this been it's been a little
more than an hour do you want to do it
yeah we do it I think you're good with
items you might as well just do it
are you going the right ways in this the
wet room that's what they call it listen
I said let's do it
no you were right okay cool
okay so you have that mm oh um oh disc
why can't I just say I'm just like
saying mm Oh mm oh all right what am i
doing
uh podium
I think she has it she does now loading
zero a weight passcode zero a oh so now
you got a lock on oh no no no you got to
go up to the desks that correspond to
zero a right okay okay so are you
looking at it from the podium it should
be the way we're looking at it right now
okay so this is it this is a no that's
zero okay so this one yeah assuming but
wouldn't if you're doing it from the
podium wouldn't you be looking at it
this way
no it's from this way okay if you're
positive
I'm positive
and then and then what this one right
here
bottom right of the screen this one no
no bottom right of the screen
death [ __ ] you
this one yes okay I don't did I do wrong
oh there are also Ingram insisted see
them I see those pucks yeah I don't
think okay let's do it
opposite let's do it your way okay so in
that case yeah way toward the camera
this one's zero okay yeah right
nope down yeah sure yes this one or this
one right this one yes
oh okay so they reset I think you got to
do it as Billy and Rebecca so maybe so I
need to split them up let's try just so
we're here yeah okay so you're here
don't get those hardest data I'll go
alone
yeah so get her closer though okay here
that's do Billy first yes
some okay try the other one then
this one a screen lit up that's your oh
yeah right so that's zero
a is no yeah that one sweet sweet what
was that
please don't be a monster because I
didn't bring any mall tops again night
swords yeah okay sweet so that's two
doors that could be our thing next time
okay one is off the wet room one is off
the main hall and then so let's get some
ink ribbies and let's save I don't think
there is a save session here oh there is
oh good all right let's just take them
not a bad hundreth epi no I was really
stressed out doing that yeah it was very
like foreboding they did a good job of
like stressing me out during like
nothing cool how do you feel good I
can't believe I've sat here went through
a hundred annoying I'm kidding it's been
fun listen this is the best years of
your life one day you're gonna be old
and dying and you're gonna be like
everybody's dying I remember when I did
the Knievel's and I liked that time I
spent can't wait to tell my
grandchildren about
I'm just kidding they can find out for
themselves thank you so much by going to
GameSpot's youtube channel and watching
them oh there's a clever plug this the
world's gonna be done by then yeah sweet
Mary's drawers organized over by then
Mary's compilation will probably also be
up on YouTube and so right now yeah see
you can watch it there and also you guys
can always hit us up on our Twitter's
we're always down to talk Knievel's
we'll hang out with you guys call out
some of the regulars while we're here
okay
so Ava Cassandra always helping out does
awesome fan work like I said I might
have some more stuff on that front soon
to commemorate 100 episodes
Nathan Shepard as always the stats oh
let me catch you up before today the
stats were as such Tom's got spoiling
this one with a few more shoes than
usual
statistics of the place through thus far
only one death well - but you wiped so
it's still a death but maybe Nathan if
you're feeling extra nice you can put
like an asterisk next to one of them no
I died thirty nine kills twenty-nine
zombies for services mmm one mimicry
Marcus one stinger for plague crawlers
chewed on by Tom nine not by like four
today I think I was not five health
recoveries four saves that's now six
also yes yeah for all the people that
wanted to know the urinal story that was
pretty much it you can find was not joke
said
[Music]
everybody I'm sorry if I'm skipping over
anybody we really appreciate everybody
hanging out every week absolutely
again Nikko thank you for the tips this
week yes Haley Hooper has been around
for a long time as well since like day
one I think yeah looking forward to next
thank you yeah and I do uh did you try
to look as much of the comments as
possible cuz they do help me like I
decided to play as two people today
because of that says hope again Xavier
did a those Funko mock-ups of Mikey and
us too and I have my headphones over my
eyes it's pretty and we're drinking
Tecate reporter jose says what up mother
lovers Stevie Sanders always high-energy
on every episode thank you for joining
us all the time we really can show you
guys so don't forget to Like and
subscribe so that we can keep doing
these for other another hundred more
yeah so thanks a lot guys
really appreciate it and we will see you
guys again next week for another for the
hundred and first the penultimate
penultimate episode of knievel see you
guys again next time enjoy